字幕: Mika Ikeda
校正: Hiroko Kawano
（拍手）
あー 今日はもう本当
１週間の始まりである日曜日に
わざわざお越しいただいて
本当にありがとうございます
今から15分ぐらいの
トークですけど
これからする 僕のトークは
僕から皆さんへの挑戦状です
ぜひ集中して
聞いていただければと思います
では 早速 時間を遡りたいと思います
レコードの時代
CDの時代がありますが
僕が生まれたのはその間の
カセットテープの時代です
カセットテープって言うと
最近 学生に通じないんですよね
そこでジェネレーションギャップを感じて
結構落ち込みますが
若い人向けに説明すると
テープに曲がつながって記録されているのが
カセットテープです
だから巻き取られたテープの厚みで
今どの辺かっていうのを推測したり
あるいは 頭出しを
パッとできないんですよ
だからキュイーンって
テープを巻いて 巻いて 巻いて
そして巻き戻したりしていました
その後ですね
CDの時代がやってきます
そこではですね
僕はCDを売る会社を作るぐらいに
音楽制作に 夢中になっていました
特に電子楽器が大好きで
収集家と言ってもいいです
たくさん集めてました
最近はですね 昔持っていたドラムマシン
という楽器がリバイバルされたので
また衝動買いしちゃったんです
やーこの業界 本当楽器っていうのは
定期的にリバイバルされて
そして定期的に僕も
買っちゃうから病気ですね
ちょっと再生してみましょう
（ドラム音始まり）
（ドラム音終わり）
フー！カッコいいですねぇ
ありがとうございます
（拍手）
あの そこに楽器屋あるのよ
だからね みなさんも
ぜひ触ってみてください
こういうのはフェーダーとか
スライダーっていう
こういうツマミがね よくできてて
スライダーを上下させたりとか
ツマミをグリグリするだけで
ほんま気持ちいいので
帰りあそこの楽器屋に 寄ってください
このドラムマシン
横にボタンが並んでいて
例えば４拍子の曲作るの
すごい簡単なんですけど
５拍子みたいな奇数のだと
非常に作りにくいので
僕は オリジナルの５拍子ドラムマシンを
ソフトウェアで作っていました
よいしょっ こんなやつですね
（ドラム音始まり）
ちょっと形が違いますけど
さっきと同じです
ボタンが赤くなっているところで
音が出ています
（ドラム音）
（ドラム音終わり）
こんな感じで—
そして僕はオリジナルの楽器を作る一方で
音楽の研究もやってたんですね
音階ありますが —
音階は ドレミファソラシの７音ごとに
オクターブ上がっていくのは
皆さんもご存知の通りですね
半音だと黒鍵が５個だから 12個ですね
12個の半音ごとに
オクターブ上がっていきます
なので オクターブ上がっても
響きは同じっていう風に見なして
曲があったら それの中に
例えば「レ」は何回 「ミ」は何回
「ファ」は何回みたいに
音の頻度を集計するという研究をしていました
音階っていうのは１周して戻ってくる
オクターブで１周する螺旋構造である
っていう風に見ることもできるので
12個の半音で１周する
レーダーチャートでまとめました
レーダーチャートっていう
言葉ひさしぶりですよね
栄養バランスを見ますとかそういう時に
出てくるあのグラフですよね
つまりまん丸なほど
バランスがいいっていうやつです
歴代の作曲家を使用傾向
こうまとめるわけです
そうするとモーツァルトと
ベートーヴェン超似てるとか
あとは現代音楽になるほど
レーダーチャートが
まあるくなっていくっていうことが
わかったりします
でまあ そんなこんなでですね
楽器を作ったり 音楽を研究したり
そういうことをしていたら
大学の先生になってしまいました
まあそのころはですね もはや
コンピューターを使う時代なので
研究室ではそれを
テーマにしています
例えば ネットで動画見る時
下にシークバーってのがありますよね —
こういうやつです
テープの厚みみたいに
どこにいるかがわかって
クリックするとジャンプできるんですが
これがシークバーではなくて
ロープだったらってことを考えるんですね
こうすると輪にできます —
輪にすると リピート再生ができる
そしてそのまんま
シークすることもできるというわけです
次はビデオ編集
ビデオ編集は 映像を撮影したスマホを並べて
そしてスマホを挟むジェスチャーで
つなげると再生するってことです
その順につながって
再生されるというわけですね
構成変えたいと思ったら
スマホ自体を入れ替えて
やはりスマホを挟む
ジェスチャーでつながります
その順につながって
再生されるというわけです
最近はですね ３Dプリンタみたいな
ものづくりの道具も
うちの研究室では 駆使しています
３Dプリンタ 見たことありますかね？
これは電気屋にあるので
今日は楽器屋の次は
電気屋 寄ってください
左にグルグル巻いあるやつ
これフィラメントっていうんです
フィラメントっていう
柔らかいプラスチックの紐です
これをチューっと上から
溶かしながら盛り付けて
なんでも形作れるっていうのが
３Dプリンタです
ここにあるようなものも
僕の名札も３Dプリントしたものです
音楽の研究ではですね
レーザーカッターっていう
穴を開けたり紙を切ったりする
っていう道具を使います
これで何ができるかというと
（オルゴール音）
オルゴールができるんですね
穴が開いているところで
音が鳴るっていうことができます
そのためのソフトも作りました
どこに穴を開けようかな？っていうのを
試行錯誤して置いてみたり
それを実際にパソコンの上で
聞いてみるっていうことが できるものです
（オルゴール音）
２Dプリンタも実は
宮下研[究室では] 大活躍なんですね
最近電気が流れるインクっていうのが
Amazonで買えるんですよ
電気が流れるインクを家庭用の
インクジェットプリンターに入れると
そのプリンターで電気回路とか
印刷できちゃうんです
いい時代ですよね
そのプリンターで縞模様を印刷して
iPadみたいなものの上に置くと
「タッチパネルが反応するわ」ってことを
実は僕たち発見しちゃったんです
これをシールみたいにして
例えばスマホの横に貼ると
横を撫でるだけで
スクロールができちゃうとか
ちょっとパターンをデザインする —
ホイールみたいなデザインにすると
グルグル回すとスクロールする
みたいな感じで
昔懐かしいiPodも
こういう感じでしたよね
またこのホイールを
ダンボールに印刷しちゃう
そうするとスマホを中に入れて遊ぶ
ゴーグルが作れます
『パックマン』のゲームとかですとね
時計回りにググってやると
前進するんですね
これですごい臨場感たっぷりに
『パックマン』が遊べるというものです
モンスター怖いです
さらに電気が流れるフィラメント
っていうのもあるんですね
そうするとこのホイールを
３Dプリントすることができて
だからこうやってひねると
スクロールするものを作ったりとかですね
あとはブロックを置いて魚を巻き上げる
釣りゲームみたいのもできます
つー感じですね うちの研究室
宮下研究室では
いろんな領域で発想力を
駆使したアプローチをしています
今日はせっかくの機会なので
その秘訣を教えたい というわけです
それは 普段から僕たちは
「共通点を見つける練習」を
しているっていうことなんです
ちょっとわかりにくいので
具体的な例をもうひとつ見せます
ある時私たちは
『毛筆の物理シュミレーション』っていう
すごい難しい論文を読んだんですね
毛１本１本があって これがどう衝突して
どう曲がっていくかっていうのを
コンピューターで
バラララーっと計算しまくると
リアルに最終的にどういう風に
かすれるかっていうのが計算できて
リアルな書が書けますっていう話なんです
ところがですね このソフト
その挙動を予測するのが難しくて
結局なかなか 使いこなせないらしいんです
笑い話みたいなもんですが
この時なんか「過去に似た経験したことある」
って僕は思ったんですね
そう 実は そういう電子楽器
僕持ってたんです
すごい高級なやつで
物理シミュレーションで
リアルな音が出せるつってるんですが
もう挙動が予測できなくて
このシンセマニアの僕でも
使いこなせなかったんです
結局そういう時に
僕は一番使いやすかったのは
「サンプラー」っていう楽器なんですね
これはすごいシンプルで
録音した音を再生する機械です
例えばピアノだったら いろんな鍵盤の音を
こうやって録音しといて
キーボードに合わせて
その音を出すわけです
すごい簡単でしょ？
あとですね何千万円もする
すごい高級なピアノとかを
プロが録音した素材っていうのも
売ってたりしたわけです
すごい使いやすかったし
ちゃんとリアルだったんですよね
これは「書道における
サンプラーって作れんじゃね？」
っていうのをやりました
すなわち 例えば
この書が格好いいと思ったら
線をなぞる —
なぞるとそれがまるで
録音された音の
波形のように記録される
こういう風にしてしまうと 後は
自由な線を何度でも書くことができます
また 線がかすれ始めるポイントを
後から調整するってことも簡単です
これもね楽器のサンプラーにあった機能を
書道に適用しただけなんですよ
そして更にプロの書道家に
線を提供してもらいまして
表現力を高めているというわけです
これもサンプラーと同じ考え方
何となくわかりました？
このように例えば 楽器と書道
全然離れた世界だけど
共通点を見つければ
新しい世界がひらけることもある
というわけです
共通点を見つけるっていう
話をしましたが
この共通点を見つける姿勢っていうのは
実は科学者としての姿勢
でもあることをアピールしましょう
かつてニュートンは
リンゴが垂直に落ちるのを見て
天体の動きとの共通点を
見つけたわけです
リンゴが落ちるのも
月が地球の周りを回るのも
両方とも重力による現象だ
っていうことを発見したわけですね
[練習問題]
ということで ではみなさん
ニュートンになったつもりで
練習しませんか？
例えば リンゴと月の軌道みたいに
直線的なものと円形のものが
実は同じ現象だっていうこと
よくあるんですよ
あるいは直線運動と回転運動を
相互変換する仕組みっていうのも沢山あります
そういうものが周りにないか
ぜひ考えてみましょう
例えばさっき出てきた地球 —
「この3次元の球体を
2次元の地図にしましょう」ってなったら
「メルカトル図法」とか
「正規方位図法」があるわけですね
赤道を直線として切り開くか
赤道を円形のまんまに残すか
これは見方は違いますが
同じ地球なわけです
相互変換の例も
サッとやっときますね
例えば回転運動を直線運動に
変換するのはタイヤとかね
回転すると車は前に進むわけです
逆に直線運動を回転運動に
変換する例だと水車ですね
水がまっすぐ流れると車が回る
そういう感じです
だんだんわかりました？
バラバラな事柄も共通点を見つけると
おもしろいように つながっていくんです
みなさんもぜひ やってみてくださいね
どうもありがとうございました
（拍手）
[ところで、]
ところでですね みなさん
ここまでのプレゼンに隠されていた
共通点にいくつ気づきました？
実はみなさんに対する
本当の練習問題
それはこのプレゼン自体だったんです
へ？って感じかもしれませんが
だって僕１番最初のスライドから
1時10分の時から
これが「共通点を見つける練習」
だって書いてましたよね？
じゃあ答え合わせのために
巻き戻してみましょうか？
はいサンプリング書道
これは直線と円を
変換できる例のひとつです
『パックマン』
これも指を回すと前進するので
タイヤと同じです
iPodのホイール
これもグルグル回転すると 縦スクロール
横に動かすやつも同じですね
同じ機構で
電子楽器におけるスライダーを
つまみに変換したようなもの
かもしれません
釣りゲームは
糸を巻き取る操作だとすると
3Dプリンター
これは逆にフィラメントを
送り出す操作ですね
その巻き取る操作と
送り出す操作両方持ってたのって
カセットテープですよね
送り出しと巻き取り 両方入ってます
オルゴールも テープと同じですね
床に固定して
回転操作によって紙を押し出します
そしてソフトの方では紙を固定して
時間軸の方を動かすという
トリッキーなことをしていました
ちなみにオルゴールで
リピート再生する方法わかる人？
答えは直線上のテープを
シークロープみたいに輪にすれば
回転運動になって
同じ曲を聴き続けられるんですよね
だんだんわかってきました？
はい この図！
この図も直線運動と
回転運動だらけですね
僕たちのシークロープ —
昔あった楽譜 それを足しても
なんだかこう 直線と円
直線と円 直線と円
ずっと交互にリバイバル
されているかのようです
なんだか進んでるんだか
進んでないんだかわかりませんね
僕たちの時代っていうのは
直線的に進化しているみたいに
見えますけど
もしかしたら１オクターブで戻ってくる
そういう螺旋構造なのかもしれないなと
常々思います
その度に買うから おかしいんですけどね
「メルカトル図法」と「正規方位図法」
それが同じ地球を表していたと同じで
棒グラフとレーダーチャート
それも同じ現象を表していました
そしてドラムマシンも見せましたが
これも直線状のドラムマシンと
円状表現のドラムマシンがありました
そして一番最初に見せたスライドですよ
スケジュールにおける時間表現
日曜日から始まる１週間という
僕たち人類が使っている７拍子のリズムとか
時計の12拍子の
リズムがありますね
７っていう数字にも
共通点ありますね
そう偶然ですが
ドレミファソラシド
日月火水木金土も同じ７つで
「ド」で始まったり「土」で終わったり
しているみたいです
積み重なった鍵盤は
伏線として見せたつもりです
そして12という数字にも
共通点があります
もうわかるでしょう
12の半音で１周する
レーダーチャート
これはちょうど時計と
同じなわけです
ということでちょうど時間です
フー 最後にメッセージを
もう一度言いましょう
「共通点を見つける練習」
をしましょう
何か共通点を見つければ
バラバラなことも
スマホを挟むジェスチャーで
つながっていくはずなんです
本当に終わりです —
どうもありがとうございました
（拍手）